Selenium.
So selenium is an element that’s quite like
sulphur. But, sulphur has its
common form in S8 rings whereas selenium exists
in its more common
form as long chains of selenium atoms and
if you shine light on these
chains they start conducting electricity.
So selenium was the material
that was used in the early photo cells for
things like burglar alarms and
doors that open themselves and so on.
So here is a sample of selenium and we’re
going to unpack it from the
box here. And it’s in the form of a shot.
Selenium has a number of other applications
and perhaps the one that
amuses me most is that it’s used in shampoos.
Some people, as you
know, get dandruff which is caused by bacteria
on their scalp and if you
use a compound which is a ring, which is a
mixture of sulphur and
selenium, this can be added to shampoo and
will act as a bactericide and
will kill bacteria that cause dandruff.
So let’s see what comes out. I can hear
it and here you can see the
selenium, wonderful black compound. Beautiful
element, again this is a
mineral which is useful for us and in fact
many people often take
selenium as an additive to their diet.
However you have to be careful because the
compounds that make our
sweat smell are sulphur compounds, so if you
get selenium into the body
then you make similar compounds of selenium
but which smell much
worse. And so it is said that people get off
the bus when selenium
chemists get on. And tellurium is even worse
still.